you know what we got into a great
conversation the other day Segway should
I bring it up it's too long of a
conversation you can't tell me what is
it I got to tell me what okay can anyone
in this room or anyone at all in the
world
kill a 900 pound cow with their bare
hands with no weapons well what I can't
use anything can't use anything just
hands bare hands if you have to think
about the thickness of cowhide - boom so
you can treat cowhide do we have a time
limit
uh no no time limit sure is it alive its
alive can you kill it I'm gonna grope
you after that we just have to impale it
no no no you have to kill a wasabi nut
that out right now
she's a cut that cut it all up just cut
that out
okay is no can't that happen yeah now
can it happen Oh 100% yes one high
percent yes give me away it's a ton nine
hundred pound cow a cow not a bull a cow
doesn't matter a cow bullseye Mart
Esther Allah's grace how do you do it
then with your hands well if you have
all the time but you can use a hold on
you can't just bite into it with your
teeth it's react no I don't know what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to well I
don't know I've never done it so then
you can use clothing no no the first
thing I will do is I would climb on its
back sure I would climb on its back okay
and just lay there thinking yeah and I
would try different things like I would
do psych you know have you ever been
next to a cow never seen one yeah yes we
have baby in the Philippines but it was
a skinny yeah but those are Filipino
they're not the real one it's just they
just they just don't look like in the
photo yeah
in the Philippine weird look they're
like they're like roosters you know have
like we have good roosters and they I
don't know I probably know about a
Filipino restaurant in Glendale called
max is it good and they have good or
Chari curry and they have good bye
sexist classics just the classics
basically but if you need a really good
Filipino restaurant I can give you okay
what about Friday Filipinos and Asians
in general are really good with fried
chicken we get fried pork is our thing
okay we have roasted chicken that's
really good but their corks I think hey
Bobby how good is create our Koreans
with fried chicken wings [ __ ] great
right do you ever go the one on 6th
Street what's it called yes what about
the cowl dilemma the debacle
the answer is you cannot Tyler over
there puffy eyes andre agassi thinks you
can and I'm like no okay just quickly
how would just give me a runway crouch
though yeah yeah yeah eat the mic I'm
just saying that you can't say that
there is not a beggar
if Bear Grylls were to be in this pen or
whatever we have setup for this cow yeah
he he wouldn't he wouldn't get killed by
the cow I'd be in a pen with a cow I
wouldn't be killed by it so I have a
week to kill this cow I think we're
repeatedly kicking it I know they have a
tough school you could break all their
legs slowly one a day yeah a 900-pound
cow's leg I'm not doing anything with
900 pounds I'm breaking one leg
yeah that's not 900 pounds break one leg
it supports 900 pounds so it's easy to
break no it's got all that weight
working against it you jump kick two
feet right into the side of the knee
happens in football all the time break
one leg let it relax for a bit
it's how wolves kill here's how I know
here's how I know you're wrong I just
thought of it there was a documentary
called Zoo okay it was about a guy dying
up in Washington because a horse [ __ ]
in the butt yeah yeah right a horse
bailed his organs as Helles organs and
all his guts came out of his Baja yeah
that's what you could do to the cow too
with your fin no no but but think of it
right think of it they'll dude it says
what why [ __ ] a horse when you can [ __ ]
a cow because there's something about
them they don't have that's why people
don't them you've never heard died
because he [ __ ] the horse the horse
[ __ ] him yeah yeah either way the cows
not gonna [ __ ] you why they're girls
these are girls unless it cowgirl do you
walk away walk away yeah anyway no that
don't make any sense
no that
what's wrong with you I know when I was
saying it in my head I'm like nothing
this is nothing your face believed I
know thank you
anyway what a great podcast I was
[Music]